Digamos que tengo el siguiente número, voy a
escribirlo, y lo que quiero hacer es pensar
cuántas centenas, cuántas decenas y cuántas
unidades tengo. Bueno, para averiguarlo podemos
mirar el valor posicional. Entonces sabemos que
esta de aquí es la posición de las unidades,
sabemos que esto nos dice cuántas decenas
tenemos -tenemos 3 decenas- y esto nos dice
cuántas centenas tenemos. Puedes ver que este
número, 832, es lo mismo que 8 centenas -porque
8 centenas es lo mismo que 800-, más 3 decenas -3
decenas es lo mismo que 30: 10 + 10 + 10, 10, 20,
30-, y luego 2 unidades, que es lo mismo que 2. Y
entonces podrías escribir 832 como 800 + 30 + 2, y
esta forma de aquí se llama notación desarrollada,
y eso tiene sentido porque parece que has
desarrollado o extendido este número, lo escribes
en términos de un cierto número de centenas,
decenas y unidades. Veamos otro ejemplo que quiero
que hagas por tu cuenta. Digamos que tienes este
número que estoy escribiendo. Pausa este video y
ve si puedes escribirlo en notación desarrollada.
Bien, ahora hagamos esto juntos. Es la misma
idea. ¿Cuántas centenas tengo aquí? Bueno, podría
ir a la posición de las centenas y ver que hay 4
centenas, 4 centenas es lo mismo que 400, y luego
en la posición de las decenas tengo 1 decena, y
1 decena es lo mismo que 10, y por último, pero
no menos importante, en el lugar de las unidades
tengo 5, hay 5 unidades, entonces esto es lo mismo
que 400 + 10 + 5 en notación desarrollada. Ahora,
¿qué pasaría si fuera al revés?, ¿qué pasaría si
te diera algo en notación desarrollada como esto
que estoy escribiendo?, ¿cómo escribirías esto
como un número? A veces la gente simplemente llama
a esto notación estándar. Bueno, quizá podrías
decir si sumo 700 a 4 obtendré 704, y eso es
correcto, o podrías pensar en ellos en términos de
valores posicionales. Si pensamos en la posición
de las centenas, la posición de las decenas y
la posición de las unidades, ¿cuántas centenas
tenemos aquí? Podemos ver aquí que tenemos 700,
así que ponemos un 7 aquí; ¿cuántas decenas
tenemos?, bueno, aquí no tenemos nada expresado
en términos de decenas, por lo que podemos
escribirlo como 0 decenas, y por último, pero
no menos importante, ¿cuántas unidades tenemos?,
vemos eso aquí: 4, así que puedes escribirlo así.